socialism is responsible for 100 million
deaths more people than fascism a single
rocket hitting the center of the city
killed 11 people it also increases
poverty so why does it appeal to so many
people democratic socialism is about
young politicians say socialism will
help the poor at in a modern moral and
wealthy society no person in America
should be too poor to live don't they
know that socialism creates more poverty
the oil-rich country is now leading
Latin America in what is called acute
malnutrition even people who understand
that socialism is bad for the economy
may not know that socialism almost
always leads to violence 120 people
would kill during 2017 why does
socialism lead to violence
socialism gives absolute power to the
state no one is allowed to own private
property or trade yet everywhere under
socialism people still do maryanne is
able to find a listing for diapers the
black market online price is almost 10
dollars cheaper people have to trade in
the black market to survive but then
government gets violent
they throw some of them in jail my
father was a political prisoner for
almost a decade because he's in his 20s
sold soaps and perfumes and did not want
to relinquish all his profits to the
government
today in America capitalism is vilified
but if capitalism is so bad why hasn't
there been a max that mass exodus out of
America because of capitalism sorry you
just don't see it socialism is like the
perfect perfect excuse for someone who
wants to rule an authoritarian regime as
people rebel against government controls
the politicians to preserve their power
use violence to stop them and they threw
me out on the floor and they started
kicking me they tortured him asking who
organized the protests how did you
answer I said the people are just tired
of Daniel Ortega Ortega has governed
Nicaragua for twenty-two of the last 39
years in Nicaragua people have again
fallen for Daniel Ortega and his
socialist promises
well inland but under his policies
Nicaragua has gone from one of Central
America's safest countries to one of the
most dangerous in Venezuela where there
are similar protests this man was a
major in Caracas the Minister of
Interior Affairs was call me several
times a week asking me to use the police
department that I was in charge of to go
against protests in check out
[Music]
the mayor refused to have his police
punish the protesters so he was
threatened with jail he then escaped to
America
why do you think Venezuela followed the
same path when we had Cuba's example for
decades and it was terrible yeah well
seems to me we're not able to learn they
will always be dreaming about the future
and never delivery and people keep
falling in love with that camera kind of
crap they do socialism repeatedly leads
to violence and yet around the world
people pray sit I don't think they
realize how deep socialism is involved
in all that this man fled Nicaragua he
understands America is a great country
and people really don't appreciate it
much they should travel a little more to
poor countries to really get a feeling
for what they have here in the United
States look around just look around you
know and really get some knowledge